You speak frequently in your lectures about,
I guess the war between good and evil or the struggle of life really is a
struggle between good and evil being at the core of a conscious lived existence.
And I guess on that note,
if you were 100% certain that there was no afterlife,
would you still be able to preach that there's a positive meeting in life?
If you're 100% certain,
some atheists seem to be 100% certain and yet they still preach that there's
some positive meaning to life,
would you be one of those or would you turn into cane?
You know,
so cynical.
I think that,
well for as far as I'm concerned,
one of the things I learned from studying 20th century history is that like even
if the idea that even if you take the most cynical of ideas,
let's say that life is irredeemable suffering and perhaps isn't even justified
because of that,
it still seems to me that you have an ethical duty,
let's say to live in a manner that reduces that to the degree that that's
possible.
And so,
and I think that that can be experienced as meaningful in some sense
independently of the transcendent context.
Now I don't exactly know how to strip off the transcendent context because one
of the things I would say that's happened to me is because I've spent so much
time looking at the horrible things that people have done is that it's like
young said that he wanted,
this is one of his famous quotes.
He said,
no tree can reach up to heaven unless its roots reached down to hell.
And so as I've dug deeper into the depravity of human beings,
my sense of the possibility of human beings has also grown.
What would you say in proportion and until I've become convinced actually that
good is a more powerful force than evil,
even though evil is an unbelievably powerful force.
And so I can't really strip the transcended away.
Now whether what bearing that has on eternity say on an afterlife?
I mean,
I,
I can't say anything about that.
The only thing I guess I can say is that there are many things about being that
we don't understand in the least.
And we don't understand the nature of consciousness or the nature of time.
So I,
I'm not,
I wouldn't despair about that,
but yes,
I think that life can still be meaningful without,
without there being a necessity of an afterlife.
So.